AND THE SEATTLE KRAKEN WITH A
POWER PLAY M M
GAMES.
WHAT A PERFECTLY PLACED
ONE-TIMER.
LOW TO THE GLOVE SIDE OFF THE
BACK FOR MORRISSEY.
MORRISSEY THROUGH TRAFFIC.
GRUBA 21 POWER PLAY
GOALS FOR IN THE LAST 25 GAMES..
HERE COMES PERFETTI CROSS-ICE I.
AND
>> Kevin: CHANCES AT BOTH ENDS.G
CONNOR WITH 44 POINTS IN 40  GO
AND PUCK
HERE COMES LOWRY.
DONATO IN ON THE
CHANCES SHORT WE'RE
STARTING THE SECOND PERIOD, THE
FINAL 1:26 OF THIS POWER PLAY
DOWN BY ONE.
AND THEY KILL OFF THE PENALTY TO
PIERRE-LUC DUBOIS.
WHEELERKevin: YOU TALK ABOUT A G
ON A PENALTY KILL.
CONNOR GOES AFTER IT.
AS SCHEIFELE E  FRONT
HE CREATES THIS TURNOVER JUST
WITH HIS IQ.
DUBOIS ON FOR PERFETTI.
DOWN FOR WHEE HIS
OWN NET.HEMISTRY THE
THREE OF THEM TOGETHER.
THERE'S JUST A BALANCE OF
EVERYTHING.
SPEED WITH  LINE.
SENDS IT ON FOR PERFETTI. TAKES
PASS.
OFF THE BACK DASHER JOHANSSON
SPINS AND FIRES.
AND WE TALK ABO THE
ATTACK ON FOR KYLE CONNOR.
CONNOR PUTS ON THE BRAKES.UP.
OVER THE SHOULDER.
THERE'S THE STOP-UP.
YOU PULL TWO G
OVER THE TOP OF THE NET.
VESALAINEN AFTER THE LOOSE PUCK.
OFF THE BACK OF THES' ZONE.
SCHEIFELE ON THE LOOSE PUCK. TI
CONNOR TO  EARLY JANUARY.
>> Kevin: THEY HAVE BUILT
THEMSELVES INTO THIS GAME.